each team out of timeouts Aces by one
8.8 to go in the fourth quarter of game
four here we go unesc to inbound trying
to get it to Stewart dumps it in Stewart
juggles catches 6 seconds left Stewart
with five draws the double lady to the
corner Vander Lo no and that is it an
unforgettable finish to game
four a resilient conclusion
to a remarkable
season for the Las Vegas Aces and for
the first time in 21 years the WNBA has
a backto back
Champion the aces on top yet
[Applause]
again
incalculable grit from Asia Wilson and
the Las Vegas Aces without their floor
General without their starting
center they beat the Liberty at corkley
Center
70-69 the
[Applause]
final New York had a tough time even
inbounding the basketball look at the
toughness shown here Alicia Clark
preventing her from going in Jackie
young helping and then recovering out to
the corner to contest the shot
phenomenal team defense
Ryan the aces have talked all season
about their Synergy how connect Ed they
are as a group on the floor and often
you see it in the way they scrambled on
that final defensive possession and a
second title for a young woman who is
quickly becoming one of the greatest
this game has ever
seen